el destino de la presidencia de ciril
Rama fosa depende de un hilo con una
creciente presión para que renuncie Solo
dos días después de la publicación de un
informe condenatorio que concluye que
violó leyes de corrupción los miembros
del CNA el partido del presidente están
dispuestos a celebrar una reunión de
emergencia este viernes para discutir
sobre el futuro de Rama fosa
todas las opciones están sobre la mesa
pero lo importante no son tanto los
méritos o los de méritos de una opción
concreta
Lo importante es elegir un camino o una
vía que en primer lugar redunde en el
interés del país
hasta en el punto de mira desde junio
por el escándalo fala fala el nombre de
su granja se le acusa de haber ocultado
un robo en su granja de caza en 2020 en
el que según él robaron 580 mil dólares
que estaban escondidos en un sofá que el
presidente asegura eran fruto de una
venta de animales el próximo martes el
parlamento decidirá si abre un
procedimiento de destitución una medida
apoyada por la oposición apoyaremos los
pasos hacia una comisión de destitución
porque creemos que es importante que el
presidente rinda cuentas y también
celebrar elecciones anticipadas pero
esta requerirá una mayoría de dos
tercios de los votos en la asamblea
donde el CNA goza de una cómoda mayoría
rama fosa por su parte siempre ha
prometido erradicar la corrupción asumió
el máximo cargo de Sudáfrica de manos
del expresidente Jacob zuma que dimitió
tras verse envuelto en varios escándalos
por